- [Robert] Las Vegas,
welcome to our session,
"Build and Optimize Edge Architectures
for Resiliency with AI."
It's a 400 level code talk,
and if this is your first code talk,
it's also my first code talk.
We're super excited to take
advantage of this format.
Previously, we've had
things like chalk talks,
we've had a chance to whiteboard,
"Hey, this is what we think
this could look like."
Or a workshop, "Hey, come follow
along with me as we build."
But now we have an opportunity
to code in front of you.
This is live, anything could happen,
but we think it's a really exciting format
to learn and build together.
And because we have a nice,
small and intimate room setting,
we highly encourage questions.
So if you want to see us build
or tweak something different,
we'd love to hear your feedback.
But by way of introduction,
I'm Robbie Belson.
I'm a developer advocate
based in New York City.
I focus on hybrid and edge services,
and specifically its application
with generative and agentic AI.
And my co-pilot for this afternoon
is the (indistinct)
- Hello, everyone.
- Jesus Federico, you
wanna introduce yourself?
- [Jesus] Sure, hi everyone,
my name is Jesus Federico.
I'm a principal solution architect
with focus on generative AI.
I used to work for the Telco Vertical,
now I'm focused on fully on gen AI part.
- [Robert] Fun fact, we
used to both work together
in the Telco Vertical.
So we've been working hard
on related topics here
for well over a year, and excited to share
not only what we've developed here,
but what we've been learning
from customers in some of their feedback
and how it applies to some
of these best practices.
So before we start coding,
since we have an hour together,
I think the theory is very important,
what we're doing and why we're doing it.
And I think it's always helpful to start
with a level-setting exercise
because I find, you know,
even as we go turn back the
clock to re:Invent 2019, what?
Six years ago when we first announced
a lot of these AWS
hybrid and edge services,
Outposts, Local Zones, Wavelength Zones,
all part of this cloud
continuum, we wanted
to create a consistent
set of AWS services,
the same set of APIs,
operational consistency,
and the same services
you know and love exactly
where developers and
builders need it most.
So just by way of hands,
how many of you have had a chance
to experiment with a Local Zone
or an Outpost or a Wavelength Zone?
Okay, so I think I see two or three hands.
that is super consistent
across all the six re:Invents
that I've had a chance to build with.
We often find that these sessions,
folks come who are new
to all of these services.
So we always figured, you know,
even though it's a 400 level
chalk talk, we want to start,
or code talk rather, we
wanna start with the basics
and recognize that many of you have yet
to build across that cloud continuum.
Many of you have built on our AWS Regions,
but if you haven't had a chance to build
with some of these other services,
the fundamental question we asked was
how could we bring these cloud services
you know and love closer to where
that data is being produced and consumed,
or in a city near you, or
within the customer premise?
So just to define our terms as we go
from the left to the right,
you take that broad and deep
set of services in the region
and you can extend it to metro areas
where maybe no such AWS
region exists today.
And that's what we'll
call an AWS Local Zone.
We can further extend those cloud services
you know and love to the customer premise.
42U rack, mountable compute
that we bring to the customer premise,
we call that an AWS Outpost.
And we have a number
of other services here
that service the customer premise,
such as EKS Hybrid Nodes,
where virtually any physical
or virtual machine can connect back
to remote Kubernetes
control plane managed by us
in EKS Hybrid Nodes.
And then of course, a number of services
to support far edge devices.
We're gonna focus today most
on Local Zones and Outposts.
We see a lot of customers.
So Jesus mentioned we both
supported telecommunications.
It's very common for a
telecommunications customer
to think about using
Local Zones and Outposts
to help build out their network.
You might have a media
and entertainment company
using Local Zones to deliver low latency,
so to service a new metro
to get closer to those customers.
Similarly, you might see that for gaming.
But it could also be
other regulated industries
that are using Local Zones or Outposts
for data residency requirements.
All that data must be
processed in locale X.
And if you bring an
Outpost into that premise,
into your customer premise
or it happens to be within
that sovereign boundary,
well, now you've fulfilled
that requirement.
So there's a number of
different use cases.
It could be latency, it
could be for migration,
it could be for data residency.
There's a number of different use cases.
But let's jump ahead now
that we've defined our terms.
- [Jesus] Yeah, also, if
you're interested in in more
how to deploy agentic
solution on the edge,
after this session will
be another session, 302.
It's gonna be around deploying
agentic solution on edge.
- [Robert] You can just come with us.
We're supporting the session,
so you can come right along with us.
We'll run on over there.
So again, so we've defined
our terms of the services
that we're gonna be working with today,
Regions, Local Zones, and Outposts.
And we want to talk about resilience.
Of course, one of the famous quotes,
"Everything fails all the time."
How do we care for resilience?
And we define resilience as
you see here as the ability
of a workload to recover
from infrastructure
or service disruptions.
And you can think about the mental model
for resilience in three different ways.
And again, this has nothing specifically
to do with hybrid and edge
services, it's far broader.
For any region design,
you're gonna think
about high availability,
again, the resistance to common failures
through design for a primary site.
So in the case of hybrid and edge,
what we're gonna show you
and one of the key tenets is
if you're using an AWS
Outpost, it's very likely
that you're gonna wanna
have multiple compute racks
to have high availability.
Similarly, for Local Zones,
let's say you're deploying
in the northeast for a low latency,
you're gonna wanna use two Local Zones,
either in that same city
if they're available or nearby cities too,
just like you would in the region
with two availability zones,
us-east-1a and 1b, for instance.
But then you can also think
about disaster recovery.
So how do you think about backup
and managed recovery objectives?
And we're gonna show you how you can,
'cause there a lot to grasp here.
And each of these concepts
of high availability
and disaster recovery have
implications to compute,
and say Amazon EC2 or storage
and RDS databases and beyond, networking.
So the cognitive load to
have say one individual,
be an expert in all of
these design primitives
for all of the services of AWS,
as it applies to hybrid
and edge, that's a lot.
But what if we could use agentic AI,
and generative AI more broadly,
to leverage that expertise
and design systems
that help make prescriptive
recommendations
to create that resiliency.
And that's exactly what we're gonna do.
And so if we do a good job today,
in the spirit of a code talk,
if the code that we purport to
build delivers what we hope,
we hope it covers these areas.
And so we talked about the mental model
of resiliency as a whole.
I tried to define as I
think about resilience
for hybrid and edge environments,
just starting from the say most,
the simplest of primitives
and extracting out from there.
So I would say when I
think about resilience,
we probably wanna start
with site level resilience.
That there's a physical discreet location
where that compute rack and an AWS Outpost
or that Local Zone lives,
and I better hope that we
have some geo diversity.
I would hope that the
networking is resilient,
that there are different paths
to connect point A to point B
if that transfer is important
to that application workflow.
Compute resilience is
also gonna be important
that if I have, let's just say
a fundamental unit of compute,
if my application requires
three units of compute,
whatever that might be,
an instance type, a load balancer,
well, I better have more
than three units of compute
in that discreet environment.
And of course, you can
extrapolate from there.
So site level resilience,
compute resilience,
network resilience, data is important too.
So when we start, again, start to think
about high availability
and disaster recovery,
well, I want to have data resilience.
So things like clustering, replication,
and then more broadly like
operational resilience.
So not any individual primitive,
but how everything works together
as you start to think about auto scaling,
health checking, monitoring.
So if we do a good job today,
these prescriptive recommendations
for resiliency developed by an AI agent
should be able to come up with
recommendations that match those buckets.
And here's how we think we're gonna do it.
And you could of course
implement this differently,
but here is our thought.
Instead of or to compliment the experts
you may already have in
each of those domains,
what if those experts could be
represented as MCP servers?
Those MCP servers were then tools
provided to an agent complimented
by the logical reasoning
that an LLM and Amazon Bedrock might have.
It could be an anthropic model,
it could be an open weights
model, totally up to you,
and there was this agentic loop.
I will talk about more
that you have a goal
and you're gonna keep using
those tools in your tool belt.
So in this case, all the documentation
for best practices that we at AWS have,
plus specific knowledge of
how hybrid and edge works.
So what changes in the world of Outpost
and Local Zones, that we'll talk about.
I gather a bunch of data,
have I achieved that goal?
Yes? No?
Oh, not yet, I need more
information to achieve that goal.
I'll continue that loop
until I'm confident
that I've achieved that user's result.
So if we just quickly go back
to that previous slide for a second,
we're gonna use all the
resiliency perimeters
that we talked about before.
So it's not gonna just
operate in isolation here.
It's gonna look specifically
again, the API...
So it's not just knowledge of,
"Hey, what are general best practices?"
I want know my specific environment,
what's real, what isn't?
How can I make improvements?
So I'm gonna use an MCP
server that talks to my AWS,
various AWS APIs to liaise with VPC, EC2,
EBS, auto-scaling, and the list goes on
because now I can look
at my entire environment,
reconcile it with what
those best practices exist
and suggest tailored
recommendations to me.
So let's jump ahead, we're
gonna start talking about
what we are gonna build here today
from static to something more advanced.
Jesus, you wanna talk a little bit more-
- Sure.
- About what this looks like?
- [Jesus] Sure, so basically,
our idea is to start
with some configuration static file.
Normally, how we would do this before,
it's just gather information
around our environment,
see the resources that we have
in terms of locals on Outposts,
and then create a kind of first report.
It says like kind of static report,
if you think around having
all the resources and say,
"Hey, now I need to build
a best practice for my infrastructure."
Then, you are gonna put some NCP servers,
some tools to ultimately request
and fetch all these resources.
And based on the knowledge of the AWS,
the MCP documentation part,
we combine that to create a new report
that is more comprehensive, right?
And we'll be iterating of the agent
that we are gonna be building.
We are gonna be using Strands Agents.
For those doesn't know Strands,
we will talk a little bit around it
and we will talk around several
how we can use multi-pattern strategy
with the Strands using, for example,
Agent as Tool, or Swarm, or workflows.
So our goal today, again,
this is a kind of a high-level step,
we're gonna be creating a static
Python file for Discovery.
Then, we're gonna be creating a report
based on this information.
Then, using Kiro CLI,
we're gonna be integrating some MCPs.
The first one is a tool to get information
around the resources automatically,
also be using MCP to get
all the documentation
of AWS best practice around resilience.
And we will be switching this
from Kiro CLI that is
prompting into a Strands Agent,
and we'll be building a
couple of Strands Agent.
- [Robert] And maybe quickly,
just a show of hands,
how many of you over the course
of the week have had a
chance either to be hands-on
or attend a session
covering Strands or Kiro?
Okay, so good, good, that I was expecting.
So we're maybe at 60, 70% of the room.
So lucky for you, today we're going
to apply all of those
concepts that you started
to see specifically to this hybrid
and edge track of how you...
It's not just, so there
are gonna be plenty
of other sessions that show you,
hey, on a Outpost or Local Zone,
those same telecommunications
or media entertainment,
or gaming companies may be
running generative AI models
at the edge for latency
or data residency reasons.
We're flipping that
model on its head today
and saying, okay, what
you could also do is,
for your own edifice, use
generative AI tools in the cloud
to inform how you use those hybrid
and edge infrastructure
services in the first place.
- Let's move on.
- Let's do it.
- [Jesus] So first, let's
talk about a little bit
around our environment.
Again, we're gonna be using Outposts,
we are using a specific account.
It has five Outposts,
four of them are active,
one is in provisioning.
We'll be running this
in the Frankfurt region
where we have all the resources.
The first thing that we are
gonna be using is Kiro CLI.
This Kiro CLI implements behind the scenes
what we see as the agentic loop, alright?
It has the capacity of reason,
it has the capacity to
connect to the resources.
But the first thing that we're
gonna be using is Kiro CLI
to create this kind of a
static files, the reports,
and then move forward to
create the Strands Agent.
So for those that used to...
How many of you used before
Q CLI, Q Developer CLI?
Alright, Kiro CLI is
basically the evolution.
It's the integration of Q Developer CLI,
now it's Kiro CLI and it's part
of integrating of
agentic development tool.
So let's move into our
first step, let me see,
of let's create something here.
Can you switch the-
- Yep.
Demo.
- [Jesus] Yeah, so hopefully
we are using internet,
it doesn't fail, so let's
start talking with Kiro CLI.
- [Robert] And can everyone see?
Is the screen large enough?
We get, okay, great.
- [Jesus] Alright, for those
that haven't used this before,
here we are using an
agent that is default.
What we're seeing here is how
the context is being used.
So we can check more
here around the contents.
Basically, it has 3% of
being of some of the tools.
If you want to see the
tools that it has already,
it has, for example, one tool
that is called AWS1 is
the thinking report,
write/read files, and so on.
So those tools already consume
part of our content's window
because it's available
directly in the Kiro CLI.
I have some prompts here,
so, sorry, just to show you.
So I'm gonna be saying that,
"I'm presenting at re:Invent,
I'm showing live how Kiro CLI works,
and for all my requests,
save all the generated assets
and scripts to," a specific folder.
So it knows where to do the file,
so we have some kind of consistence.
Again, we're gonna be
using on a specific account
that has some of the Outposts
that we already mentioned.
So this is the profile that we have.
So here, now Kiro CLI
is validating and creating the folder.
It's already there.
So I'm ready to set up all the demos.
What are the first thing
that you want to build?
So as we explain, let's move forward
and create a static file.
I have my prompt here, so let's see.
So I'm gonna be creating a Python file
that is called
edge_discovery, that use boto3
the SDK library for Python,
to discover all the edge resources
in this particular region.
And the script must contain
and discover things
like Availability Zone,
Local Zone, Outputs.
I want to see which are the instance types
available on some of the Outposts.
And the script itself needs
to manage all this information
around error handling (indistinct)
and I want this and output as a JSON file.
- [Robert] Right.
- [Jesus] So let's start doing this
and let's analyze what it creates
so we can dive deeply a little bit.
- [Robert] And key point
to think about right now,
this is the v1.
So if we're gonna think about, again,
resiliency and reliability in
a hybrid and edge environment,
step one, even before we
think about creating an agent,
yes, we're using an
agentic CLI tool to do so,
but we're just trying to take inventory of
what exists before we create
prescriptive recommendations.
And so that's exactly what
you're gonna see here.
- [Jesus] So it already create my file.
Let's check the file.
First, let's try to run it.
If something happened, it
can automatically fix it,
but let's see if it runs,
and we can dive deep a little bit
of the code that we generated, alright?
Alright, so let's see while it's running.
So we set to create a
file that is a static,
it discovered the edge infrastructure.
Basically, if we dive deep a little bit
on the function it created,
it go to boto3 using the profile
that we set on the region and it creates
and it fetched all the information
around the Availability Zone.
It have all the information
around the zone ID, state,
if it's Local Zone, whether it's...
Where's the parent AC or the network
border group that is attached.
For the Outposts, it's
doing basically the same.
It's listing is boto3,
SDK functions to list the Outposts
and basically it's getting the information
around the Availability Zones,
the instance type available, and so on.
Also, we want to see from
the Outposts perspective,
there is a content around
that is called slotting.
So the Outpost itself is a max service,
is a hardware that a 42U hardware
that you have compute nodes
and you need to specify
what are the shapings
or the type of EC2 instance
that you want to load
and have available on that configuration.
So we want to see, in this
particular post that we have,
what are the instance types available
and also if we have some placement group,
what are the placement group that we have,
and let's see the results.
So it run, alright.
This is the information that we got.
Alright, let's dive deep
a little bit on this.
It's basically saying the
region, the Availability Zones,
and all the information that we just check
in the Python script.
Now let's move forward and say that I want
to modify this script, I want this script
to be stored in a JSON file.
Alright, it's gonna be
a simple modification.
Basically, we expect
in that it will change
a little bit the last part, alright?
So now the output will be safe here
in the edge_discovery, that JSON file.
And if we run this, it
will generate my file,
my JSON file with the
information we already saw.
- [Robert] While it's generating,
any questions about what we're doing,
why we're doing it, and
sort of the sequencing here?
Again, this is just the, we're
creating a static snapshot,
a point-in-time view of just,
"Hey, what's out there?"
Once we have that, of course,
then we'll be able to
create recommendations.
And one very key insight,
especially for those
who are seeing Outposts and
Local Zones for the first time,
these are connected edge offerings.
The Local Zone in a given metro
or an Outpost sitting
in your customer premise
always has a parent region.
It's connected to an
Availability Zone in the region.
That creates of course high availability
but it creates that connectedness
that allows you to run API operations.
And why that's important is you see
how all those Outposts has
an anchor Availability Zone,
every Local Zone is anchored to a region.
You're starting to see
how that's gonna create
high availability best practices.
You're gonna want Outposts anchored
to different Availability Zones.
You're gonna wanna have Local Zones
with different availability Zone IDs.
So those same best
practices continue to apply.
- [Jesus] Let's ask even
Kiro CLI to create a,
based on the information we have,
let's create a first static report.
Basically, we are saying like,
"Create an HTML report based
on AWS best practice for the edge
and considering the resources
that we already discovered."
- [Robert] We haven't told Kiro CLI
what those best practices are.
So it's gotta figure it out.
- [Jesus] Yeah, it will
be using the knowledge
that it was until that
model that it's using,
that is auto model, and
we'll dive deep a little bit
on more on that, but it's
using the knowledge base
that the model itself have
onto the cut point time
that it was trained.
- [Robert] Right.
- [Jesus] Alright, so if we want to use,
and we will be using like,
if want to use the
up-to-date documentation,
the latest documentation,
we need to find a way
to fetch that documentation
and we'll be using an MCP tool
that provide access to the best practice
using AWS MCP documentation,
alright, for this one.
Any questions so far?
- [Audience Member] About
the MCP documentation,
(indistinct) automatically or-
- [Jesus] No, we'll be showing this-
- [Robert] Not yet, right
now it's just the knowledge
that this large language model
that's being used by default
by Kiro natively knows.
And the only reason it knows
anything about your environment
is we specifically say,
"Hey, edge_discovery.json,"
which we happen to know captured
that point of time snapshot.
- [Jesus] Alright.
- So trying to do this-
- Here we got,
we have our first, this is just generated.
- Completely live-
- We're seeing-
- [Robert] We're seeing
it for the first time.
- [Jesus] For the first time as you.
So we have here our information
where our three Availability
Zones in the us-central-1.
We have two Local Zones enabled,
we have three Wavelength Zones
and we have five Outposts.
Four of them are active, one
is in provisioning state.
And we have here all the details
of the Availability Zone,
the Local Zone, and the Outpost.
If you see the Outpost itself,
(indistinct) mentioned,
is tied to a parent AC
because when we request the Outposts,
we do something that is
called the anchor BPC
and we create a subnet in specific AC
that we want to put the control
plane go through that AC.
So we have here four Outposts,
one of the two of them in the 1a,
the one that is provisioning is not,
it doesn't have information yet,
and the other one that are spanning
across the rest of the AC.
If we see the best practice documentation,
it show a really comprehensive information
like your infrastructure
span in the three AC
with Outpost in each zone,
providing excellent
geographic distribution.
There are some recommendations around,
there is an Outpost that
is in provisioning status,
check what's going on.
And we have multiple of
instance type available
in terms of diversity.
We have several offers
around instance type
in terms of the Outpost Rack 1.
We have C5, M5, R5,
and we can also have different types here.
So again, this is kind
of static information.
We just generated the script
and now we're providing some information.
Any question?
- [Audience Member] This is
all one AWS account, right?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] What
if you wanna like try
to have multiple AWS accounts?
- [Jesus] Yeah, you can ask Kiro, say,
you can use, for example, if
you are using AWS Organization
and you have cross-role,
you can say, "Hey,"
for example, if you're using control tower
and you have a cross-role
across many, you can say,
"Hey, use this, verify
what are my accounts."
It can discover your
account and assume the role
to perform this information
across all your environment
spanning in multiple accounts.
- Right.
- [Audience Member] Would
you need to (indistinct)
when you use Kiro CLI,
like, how do you
authenticate the (indistinct)
- [Jesus] Yeah, I have here my profile.
So in the profile itself in
the AWS CLI configuration,
it has the information
around the account ID
and the profile of that
role that I'm assuming.
- [Audience Member]
Right, what I mean is...
I'm using Kiro CLI, so (indistinct)
know exactly how that
works, but every time I...
When I use it for the first time,
you know, I don't want
a profile giving a code
for the given database account,
so that I can-
- Right.
- [Audience Member] If
there are multiple accounts,
would you need to
(indistinct) every single one,
or just for the-
- Those are decoupled,
like one account is what
you would have access,
would give you access to Kiro.
But those other accounts could
simply be to pull resources.
So the simplest brute force way is
however you've authenticated
to have access to Kiro,
that remains unchanged.
But you could have your
AWS configuration file
where you typically have
your account secrets
and you could have multiple profiles.
And then in that, and
when you prompt Kiro CLI,
you can basically say, remember we created
that edge_discovery.json file?
We can basically say, "Hey,
iterate through all of
those AWS profiles."
And then given those credentials,
you're now talking to different accounts
of different resources, pull from there,
and now you have a more complete set
of resources reflecting that JSON.
Now, how you segment by account,
you would have to decide
what's important to you.
- Yeah, yeah,
- Yeah.
- [Jesus] Alright, so let's move forward.
Again, here we are not using the tools.
The tool itself is what keto CLI
has entered as default.
It has like to do, thinking.
You can enable some of these
tools in the experimental part.
So you see here, I have like to-do list,
checkpoint, delegate, knowledge, thinking.
This is our part of the Kiro CLI part.
But now I want to introduce
a new MCP, alright?
So let's create a new agent.
Let's create, it's called agent 3.
So here it's the
configuration of the agent.
Think around this, it's
like you can have multiple
Kiro CLI instances at the same time.
Think around like profiling.
So you can have one agent that has access
to different tools, different MCP.
In this particular case,
I'm gonna be adding
this knowledge base MCP.
So hopefully it works.
So we have a, this is
a public documentation.
We will be sharing a little bit of
what all the AWS MCP we have
out there so you can consume.
This particular MCP is an MCP
that provides information
around best practice,
latest documentation, dynamically, right?
So now we have created,
let's change the contents
and then say I'm gonna
be using this agent.
So if you see right now,
and I go my tool, now have new MCP here,
that it's aws-knowledge-mcp-server
that have this kind of information
and this kind of tools.
So what if we, instead of
saying create a static file,
let's make something different.
Let's say that I want to create
a HTML report of edge
resilience best practice
for my infrastructure,
but I want you to find
the latest documentation
and using the AWS tool that it has,
find the resources for me, I don't-
- [Robert] There's no JSON file anymore.
- Yeah, you are not relying-
- We're clean-slate.
- [Jesus] On anything, on any static file.
It needs to somehow with
the agentic loop figure out
what are the resources
that it needs to find based
on the best practice documentation
and it create a report for me.
- [Robert] While the report is creating,
can we take a question from the audience?
- [Jesus] Yeah, sure.
- [Audience Member] What's the difference
between the knowledge
MCP server you just added
and the knowledge tool
that's already added and why?
Are they different from each?
- [Jesus] Yeah, this one?
- [Audience Member] Yeah,
so I see knowledge there,
and I saw you got knowledge,
a second knowledge.
Just curious what the difference is.
- [Jesus] Yeah, I'm not sure,
yeah, I'll take that offline.
Kiro was rebranded like one week ago.
It used to be QCLI,
so it introduced new features
like web search and web fetch,
which wasn't before on QCLI directly.
So you can dive deep a
little bit, I don't know if-
- [Robert] Generally speaking,
the idea would be that
it's the general knowledge
that the Kiro CLI must have
for just coding in general
and any best practices for software,
whereas the more specific
guidance you can give, the better.
And so we've created, you know,
to keep update documentation
to have a specific AWS knowledge.
But it's likely to your point
that there is some overlap.
- [Audience Member] Okay.
- [Jesus] Yeah, so if
we see, ah, go ahead.
- One last question.
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member]
Focused on his question.
So the built-in knowledge,
is it basically using an MCP
default (indistinct) something like that?
- [Robert] Right, 'cause those
are all tools that it has.
And so it may not be MCP.
- Okay.
- Right?
So as you'll see later when
you create a Strands Agent,
you can just have local tools
that you'll see with like a Decker.
You have just some function
like def cool function and
then it just has some logic.
It need not be called through MCP.
That's just one way for
a protocol for different,
for an agent to talk to a tool.
So in that case, it may not
be called via MCP itself.
- [Jesus] So if we see what
is happening behind the scene,
when I ask this kind of request,
it's gonna be running the tool
to search the documentation like,
"Resilient best practice
for availability zones,"
"Outputs and failover best practice,"
"Local Zones architecture,
"Best practice," and so on.
And think around it's
getting all this information
and putting in the context
and now it needs to find
all the resources that,
because I want this
applied for my account,
it will find all the
resources using the profile,
it will run the CLI using this tool
to get all this information
and create the HTML file for us.
It's gonna take a while.
Let's go back into the presentation
to get some of the next
thing that we're doing
and we can talk a little bit
of the MCP servers we have there.
Meanwhile, and we go back to the...
So talking a little bit
of some of the MCPs,
we add this MCP,
which is the knowledge MCP server.
But there are other MCP
servers that you can use.
For example, in this particular case,
we didn't add because it was
built-in in the Kiro CLI,
but you can use Cloud
Control API MCP Server
to have access to all the resources
around your AWS infrastructure.
You basically have information around
how to access with API
and integrate with your environment.
In this particular case,
we didn't use it because
it has already tool
that is AWS tool to get that information.
Any question?
Alright, so...
So we won't reiterate this.
Let's talk a little bit around strengths
while it generates it,
it hasn't finished yet.
So we can talk a little
bit around how we...
Now we want to move out from...
We create this kind of
assessment and report,
but it was kind of interactive, right?
Like, we need to dive deep
and type what we have
in a prompting style.
What if we want to run a kind of agent
and we want to build an agent
using Python that can run,
for example, in my backend system,
I can execute and can
run every time I need
instead of having something
that I need to prompt manually.
We can create something
using a Python file
and an agent that can run in the backend.
So that's why we're gonna
be using Strands Agent.
Strands Agents are open source
SDK for building agents.
And you can use a Strands with
multiple online providers.
In this case, we're
gonna be using Bedrock,
but you can use a other provider
and it has a set of tools
that you can integrate,
use, and make it.
Wanna mention something?
- [Robert] Sure, maybe just to,
as we'll see in the code,
maybe just a few things.
When you think about an agent,
it's gotta have a model,
it's gotta have a prompt.
So the brain of how it's
able to logically reason,
the prompt to tell it what it's doing,
and then a series of tools,
the actions it can take to
deliver against that goal.
And we believe that with Strands,
it's one of the easiest ways,
specifically native to
AWS, to marry those three,
almost like Strands of
DNA that are intertwined.
And so the ability just to have like
a really, really simple
way you can create agents
in just a very few lines of code,
but also native integrations.
If you wanted to have a RAG
workflow as part of your tools,
so company-specific data,
you had a specific question
and you had that RAG workflow
and you wanted to expose it as a tool,
you could write a bunch of
extra code to do that manually
or you could just use the
native retrieve library
that's already integrated
with Bedrock knowledge basis.
So that's an example of where
the AWS integration shines
with something like Strands.
- [Jesus] So on the other hand,
now we're gonna be switching to use Kiro.
The IDE is our agentic development
platform for prototyping.
In this particular case,
we were using Kiro CLI.
Now we're gonna be using the IDE
for create our first agent.
And let's move on.
Let's see if we should have...
- [Robert] The report.
- [Jesus] The report ready.
Okay, it create the new report
and generate this report.
We can see that it have
similar information,
three Availability Zones, two Local Zones,
four or five output, one of
them is in provisioning state.
But it has also more
information around, for example,
auto scaling group, load
balancer, placement groups.
It has information also
around multiple deployments
of information of EC2
instance infrastructure
that expands across
other load balancer, for example,
that we didn't have before.
So in this particular case, again,
when we create this,
we didn't ask any specific resources
to be like static generated,
or we didn't find statically,
it just find it for us.
It basically discovered
this placement group,
Local Zones and all this stuff.
So it generate this for us
based on the documentation
that it finds and it creates the report.
So let's move into Kiro.
This is the development environment.
Again, we're gonna be using Vibe coding.
This is a code talk.
Let's hopefully it work.
So let's just start with Kiro
asking something around...
Read the documentation of Strands,
and based on the documentation of Strands,
create our first agent.
So in order to read the
documentation of Strands,
we can use an Strands MCP documentation
for showing that
we have this Strands documentation.
Let's figure out, let's create
our Strands documentation agent.
Alright, so we can use, for example,
this agent that is called
a Strands MCP agent,
basically, it run uvx comment.
But in our particular
case, you can also use,
for example, you can
retrieve the documentation
of the software that you are building.
Ask the Kiro environment
to read the documentation
if you don't have an MCP server for that,
and based on the documentation,
start building on top of that.
- [Robert] And key point that I think
you'll see here is the
configuration of this agent,
whether it's the Kiro IDE or the Kiro CLI,
was almost identical.
And you'll notice when you
specify those MCP servers,
the first time when we were looking
at the aws-knowledge-mcp-server,
it was more of a URL
because it was a remote MCP server.
In this case when we were showing Strands,
it was a local MCP server.
So it's the consistency of
defining the MCP services
or rather to define these
MCP servers, is consistent,
but it could be local, it could be remote,
it could be a combination
of both, it doesn't matter.
- [Jesus] So in order to do that,
again, I downloaded the
documentation of Strands, right?
So I'm asking to read the documentation.
Also, I create a based template
of a simple Strands agent.
So it has all the information
around my profile.
I could use even Kiro
to say, "Hey," you know,
"create a agent using this profile,"
in order to avoid kind of kind of noise.
Or we have a short time,
I want to be focused on what we have today
and focus on our configuration.
So I create a kind of base agent
that it says I'm gonna
be using this profile,
I'm gonna be using a
structural response in Strands.
That means, for example,
if you want the output
of your agent to be structure,
let's suppose that you are
returning a person object.
You want to have a name, you
have to want to have the age.
So you can create a kind of,
when you create the agent,
you say, "Hey, use a static output."
In this particular, I'm
gonna say I'm gonna be asking
for a markdown report.
So, and these are just placeholder, right?
These are our main loop and
we are gonna be creating,
using ours profile, I'm gonna
be creating a runtime client
for Bedrock with 300 seconds,
300 seconds to create the client.
Then, I'm gonna be
creating the agent itself
and asking the agent for something.
There's a place-
- [Robert] That's the most important part.
Quickly, folks, if this
is your first time dealing
with Strands, what, four lines of code?
Really three, if you exclude
the closing parentheses.
When we say you can define an agent
in three lines of code,
that's what we mean.
You see the system
prompt, you see the model,
you see the agent
instantiation, and that's it.
- [Jesus] That's it.
So I'm gonna be asking to,
using the Strands
documentation from this folder,
create an agent with a Strands
name of v1, using this base.
And basically, the
script should be running
using this model, the 300 second
is there for read timeout.
And also, we are gonna be
using some tools similar
to the static file that we created
to create some information
around get_outposts,
get_local_zone, Availability
Zone, and so on.
So behind the scenes,
it's gonna be creating
several functions to get information,
similar to the Python file
that we created at the beginning.
So let's go and ask
Kiro to do that for us.
Meanwhile, this create the file.
Alright, it's reading the documentation.
I have a backup here, we
can show how it's gonna be,
the code that it's gonna be generating.
I'm only leaving this generating the code,
but we can start reading
how the code will look like.
Shall we do that?
- Let's go.
- [Jesus] So now it's
doing, right, but let's see,
in order to get some of the time, so-
- [Robert] And let's go back to the,
I think let's start with
the agent instantiation,
show what's the same, and then let's show
what's different, what the agent did.
So we should still see-
- Yeah.
- [Robert] Somewhere in
the middle of the file,
it instantiated the agent
just like it did before, but-
- [Jesus] Yeah, let's
go to the agent part,
where we define the agent.
So we have our main part
where we have our config,
our Bedrock client, the model itself,
and now we are creating an agent.
And we are saying that
you have some tools.
Which tools are this?
Basically, we ask to create
some kind of functions
where it can fetch information
around Outpost, Local Zones,
Availability Zone, EC2 RDS you mentioned.
So in this particular case,
we are creating this agent
and the system prompt for the
agent, it's basically this.
"You are an AWS edge
infrastructure resilient expert
"and your role is to analyze
the AWS infrastructure
"deployment and provide
comprehensive resilience assessment.
"And your analysis should cover,"
and there is a lot of points
that it needs to cover.
This is being generated
right now, right away.
But I have a backup
here just to show this.
So when we create this,
we ask to create a kind of tools,
alright, like a EC2 instance, which are...
Now it's running.
Meanwhile it's running,
I'll be showing this.
So if you want to see the
tools that we created,
we ask to create like get_outposts.
So it's using boto3, the client,
to list the Outpost and
list all the resources,
pretty similar to the Python file
that we created at the beginning.
So after it run, it's running right now.
So it just created the new one.
Let's see the, not the backup,
let's see the one that
it actually created,
should be pretty similar,
which is running right now.
So it's conducting a
comprehensive AWS structure
resilience analysis on
the us-central-1 region,
and it's calling the tools.
It calling get_outposts, get_local_zones,
get_availability_zones,
instance, other stuff,
and now it's basically outputting.
It's creating my output.
This is the report that is gonna be saving
one second after it finish with my MD
with all the information that I have.
Any questions so far?
- [Robert] And I think just
a key learning objective is
no surprise that the individual tools
that are being instantiated,
like get_outposts,
is gonna be using almost identical code
to that first program we created
that describes the EC2
instances that are available
or describes the Availability Zones,
the Local Zones, and the Outposts
that are available
anchored to that region.
So it's just we're taking
these little primitives,
these functions and showing
it can be standalone Python file,
it can be part of a tool
that talks to an agent.
It can be embedded into
some remote MCP server
that our CLI or agent talks to.
It's just different ways
of using the generative AI toolkit in AWS
to get the results you need
and often much faster
than doing so manually.
- [Jesus] So now it's basically
the output of all the
information that it's providing.
Once it finish, it should generate a file
with a MD that as we ask, like the v1.
And I think it should be finishing
in a couple of seconds,
hopefully it works.
After this, we're gonna
be doing something similar
to what we did with Kiro CLI.
What if we say, "Hey, just
remove all these tools
and let's use a tool
that can provide access
to my environment,"
I don't want to define any kind of tool,
and simplify my agent saying,
"Now you are an expert.
You have access to my AWS infrastructure.
You have access to the
AWS documentation, do it."
What I need is gonna
be simplifying our code
of a Strands agent in less than 100 lines.
So, great.
Any questions so far?
- [Audience Member] I have a question.
But in terms of cost, how many
credited costs this exercise?
- [Jesus] Yeah, so when
you are running Strands,
you can use the metrics tool.
So it generates how many input tokens
and output tokens it's consuming.
- [Audience Member] So for example,
your particular exercise is one.
How much did it cost?
- [Jesus] Yeah, it should be
printing the metrics here.
I think I have...
Right now, in the base-
- [Robert] We haven't
benchmarked this exercise
and the specific number of credits
that it would consume in Kiro yet.
- [Jesus] Yeah.
- [Audience Member] I'm just curious.
- [Robert] Yeah.
- [Jesus] Yeah, so I don't
have right away the point.
But we can do that, to try
and print the metrics for you.
- [Audience Member] Yes, I'm curious.
- [Jesus] Yeah, so-
- [Audience Member] (indistinct) Design,
but how much it costs.
- [Jesus] (chuckles) Alright.
So going back to the report,
if you want to see the report,
is the MD, it has pretty
extensive documentation.
It should have also some
recommendation around buckets,
information that we didn't have before,
and also some links around documentation
and even some code of how
to modify, for example,
the load balancer that we
identified that is running,
expanding on multiple AC, and so on.
Again, if we want to
simplify this a little bit,
of the code, because now our v1 version
is more than 500 line of code
that we may not need all of them.
So what if we say that I
want to create a new version?
Alright, it's gonna be v2.
Let me show you the prompt here.
So I'm gonna be creating a new version
of this resilience agent,
but based on the first one,
but with an additional tool,
I want to configure the MCP,
the knowledge MCP server,
and also remove all the tools
to get resources from AWS instead
of use the predefined use AWS
tool that comes from Strands.
So the idea here is just
to simplify the code
and similar to what we did
in the first Kiro CLI,
it's gonna be creating a Python file
with a Strands agent
that is simple to read
and basically it's prompted.
So again, let's see
how it should look like while
it generates the code for us.
So can you read there?
Okay, so it's pretty similar.
We have the response and a
structure format output response.
But now we have a system
prompt saying that similar,
"You are an AWS edge resilient expert,
you have real access to
real time AWS documentation
and your role is to analyze
the infrastructure deployment
and provide a comprehensive
resilient report."
Pretty similar, we have our model.
Now we have this MCP client
that is a streamablehttp_client
that it has access to
the endpoint of the MCP
and we are creating an agent
that with a model, and say like,
"Now you are gonna be
using this tool, use AWS,"
this is a tool that is
embedded in Strands.
We'll see it here in Strands tool.
You can find more tools available
on the documentation on GitHub,
on the Strands tools repo.
And also now we're gonna be
using the aws_knowledge_mcp,
that it's basically
what we defined before.
- [Robert] And instead of
having all those tools,
get_outposts, get_availability_zones,
get_ec2_instances,
you could define all those tools manually
or you could have your Strands Agent
in turn be an MCP client
that connects to these remote MCP servers.
- Yeah.
- Saving you a bunch of time.
- [Jesus] Now, if you see,
it's running the v2 version.
It's using the tools to get all
the resources documentation,
and also it's using the AWS
search documentation itself.
Now it's pretty similar to
the second version that we did
with Kiro CLI saying like,
"Hey, now you have access to the tool,
now you have access to
the AWS environment,
and just figure out and do all the things
that you need in order to
get that information for me."
So once we run that,
we should get a report pretty
similar to the first one,
maybe with more details
because now it's conducting,
okay, it's printing here.
It has access to more resources
because it can think instead
of saying the static,
"Oh, you have access to a ALB,
you have access to the EC2."
It can figure out, "Oh, I need access
to the placement group.
I need access to
understand what are the S3,
how is the NLBs," or whatever resources
that are spanning in
across our infrastructure.
It's generating that.
I'm gonna be showing one that is similar,
we just created this.
But basically, the output
should be something similar
of what we are running, right?
So any question here?
Nope? Yeah.
- [Audience Member] So I
see instantiating agent,
I'm just curious about the code itself.
What's driving the event
loop or the agent loop?
Are we just like calling
agent on run and it's just-
- [Jesus] Yeah, so let's say the code
of the agent loop part here.
So the agent itself, it's basically to...
You have to select which
is the model, alright?
And you can have different
model provider here,
you can use OpenAI, you can use Bedrock.
In this particular case,
we're using Bedrock,
but you can implement even
your own provider, alright?
And then, you have a set of
tools that it's available,
the system prompt, and then you want,
when you want to call
it, it's basically agent.
It's like, "Do this, run
this execution for me."
And this is the prompt that
we're asking the agent.
The agent, what we're asking is,
"Please conduct a comprehensive
AWS infrastructure resilience analysis
for this region," is the
variable that it's passing,
"and the report must be generated on,"
the current date, alright, today.
"And include the following things,"
edge infrastructure report,
it generates that for you.
So it's kind of, you define
where is the system from,
from the agent, the tools available,
and then you ask the things.
So in order to have a
respond that is a structure,
you need to pass this argument
that is a structure output model.
And it's basically a class
that says in description mode
what is the model the agent needs
to fulfill as a response, alright?
Suppose that you can have something,
an agent that validates
information for a person.
You may need to have age,
name, address, whatever.
You may ask something
and then you can ask directly
information response,
a structural response that edge,
and you have the information there.
Clear?
We have eight more minutes, awesome.
So it's gonna be generating this.
Let's dive deep a little
bit on what we have.
While this generate,
let's talk a little bit
of how we can create
multi-agent patterns on Strands.
So now we saw information around, okay,
now we have the call, we
have access to some tools,
and we can create a new version
that has multiple agents.
Instead of having isolated tools,
what if we can create an agent
that is an expert of assist admin?
For example, AWS's admin,
it has access to your AWS environment
and it can do read
operation, write operation,
whatever is the scope of the agent.
So it has access to a specific tool.
Then, you can do an AWS
documentation expert
where it has access to the
MCP of the AWS knowledge.
And then, you can figure out and say,
"Hey, I want a coordinator
that I want you to,"
I will be sending a request
and using those agents,
it will figure out, it
will have as a tool,
it will figure out and do,
perform the action for me.
So this one is gonna be the third agent
that we're gonna be implementing if we,
ooh, I think we have time.
But then, we have other kind of pattern.
We can do something like instead
of having agents unpack that
and provide that agent as
a tool for other agent,
we can do a kind of graph
where this agent can talk with other,
in a kind of a deck, direct graph.
So we can say, which is the flow,
like I'm the researcher,
I'm gonna be passing the
information to the writer,
and the writer pass the
information to the reviewer,
and the reviewer print
the output, for example.
And this just a kind of graph information.
And then we can create a kind of workflow
that in the graph, we can go back
and we can define the
transitions going back and forth,
but it's established transition, right?
Stable transitions.
And in the kind of workflow,
it's basically a structural
coordinator of task
that we can define, "First
step, do this, second step,"
Second step, do whatever,
like researching,
like coding, right?
If we want to code an
application, maybe we need
to figure out first is
the architecture itself.
Send the coder, the tester,
and the reviewer and so on.
So we can create a kind of flow.
Third, we have the Swarm pattern.
In the Swarm pattern,
it's a kind of multi-agent
that there's no a single coordinator.
It's basically between them.
They figure out the task and they,
you can specify the Swarm
agent two different ways.
You can define a Swarm agent saying like,
"Hey, you have this complete task.
Create the agents that
are expert in this,"
in each particular area.
And each particular area,
they start talking each other
as they believe they needs to do.
Or you can specify a specific agents,
you can create agents like
AWS documentation expert,
the sysadmin expert, the report expert,
and then as a whole, say like,
"Hey, I have this problem.
Figure out how to solve it."
And they will be passing information like,
"Hey, I need to talk with the expert."
The expert saying like,
"Hey, I need to talk with a sysadmin
to get this information.
Go back to the other
documentation expert."
And they can retrieve the
information and work as whole,
sharing information across
the agent dynamically.
You want to see the code of Swarm,
how it looks like,
I have a couple of samples here.
So still generating the...
Oh, let me close this, the second.
So in the Swarm part,
we are saying here that,
again, we have our response,
but then we are creating agent one.
"You are the infrastructure expert.
Your name is Infrastructure Discovery,
and you are an agent that specialize
in discovering and
cataloging AWS resources."
So it have access to the tool, use_aws.
Second, we have an agent
that it's the Best Practice,
it has access to the aws_knowledge_mcp.
Third, we have an agent that it says that,
"What is the gap analysis?"
It doesn't have any kind of tool,
but it says based on the
specialized agent, alright,
comparing our infrastructure
versus the Best Practice,
which are the gaps," alright?
And it figure out what are the gaps
and what we need to do in order to make
our infrastructure pretty similar
or compare against the AWS Best Practice.
And then, we have the recommendation.
Again, "You are a recommendation agent.
Based on the previous information,
just gather and create an actionable
remediation plan for that."
And based on that, we create a Swarm
and it says like, "Okay,
let's create a Swarm
where we have all these agent.
The first that will receive this
is the Infrastructure agent."
You can put the Best
Practice, whatever you want.
And you have some transition
and that situation that you can take.
As we don't define how the
transition will look like,
it just start talking each other like,
"Hey, I'm the expert of this information."
So it pass information to the other one
and it just create a kind of mesh loop
instead having interaction
between all the agents.
And the Agent as Tool,
alright, which is, let
me see if this finish.
We can ask our third version
to create a Agent as Tool,
I'll be sharing here.
But the Agent as Tool,
now what we're saying is,
"Alright, now I just
want to have an expert
that it's a AWS sysadmin expert,"
and we define this as a tool.
But if you see, the implementation code
of this tool is, again, it's an agent.
So we have the same pattern.
We have an agent with a
model, we have a tool,
but we are exposing this function,
which is an agent itself,
as a tool that can be consumed
by another agent as a
coordinator agent, alright?
So we can create a kind of tree
where we have a coordinator
talking with other agents
that are being exposed as a tool.
In this case, we have a sysadmin expert
that have access to the use_aws tool.
We have a documentation expert
that have access to the MCP.
And alright, and we have
the finally the coordinator
that provide information to both tools,
and it provide information for you.
- [Robert] So that's about all
the time we have left here.
But just to give you I guess a
little bit of parting wisdom.
We recognized that we had to
make trade-offs in the session
of going all in on what
those best practices are
for resiliency while trying
to introduce all these primitives
for generative AI and
agentic AI specifically.
And we thought that to
strike a healthy balance,
we would show you how to take
or how to go from a
static resiliency report
with a simple Python file
to starting to integrate MCP servers,
Strands Agents, Kiro CLI, and Kiro's IDE.
And to take that one step further,
if you've had sessions that
you've seen around AgentCore,
you could run that Strands Agent
that we created in AgentCore.
So you don't have to run
it remotely on your laptop.
You could have it running in
that secure, isolated environment.
So we hope that this painted a picture
of what the future of, let's say,
your Well-Architected Framework
review could look like
for your applications using AWS hybrid
and edge services or otherwise.
If you're interested in getting
a little bit more hands-on
with hybrid and edge services,
come with us just across the hall here
for this next workshop.
We hope you had fun here the past hour.
Thanks for hanging out with
us and we'll stick around
to answer any questions and look
into that credits question you asked.
So thanks so much,
folks, we appreciate it.
- [Jesus] Thank you.